[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Claire patté fondatrice
et directrice artistique des
ménographies bonjour bonjour Alors du 3
au 25 juin 2023 vous organisez la
troisième édition des ménographies dans
le grand parc des mesnils quels sont les
objectifs de cet événement ah les
objectifs de cet événement c'est de
d'amener
la photo d'art en fait
à la campagne et de faire en sorte qu'on
n'est pas forcément à se rendre dans une
grande ville pour y avoir droit et
pourquoi organiser un festival autour de
la photographie est-ce que vous estimez
que cet art est assez mis en avant alors
je trouve justement que non je trouve
qu'on est peu au courant que c'est aussi
un art et pas juste un média
publicitaire donc
je trouvais ça important en fait de
mettre en avant la photographie d'art
aussi parce que pour moi elle a souvent
un message très fort et justement à
travers cet événement vous dissocier
également donc la photographie
la matrice finalement et la photographie
vraiment artistique oui alors notre
appel à candidature est quand même
ouvert aussi aux amateurs parce qu'on
est intimement persuadé qu'on peut
trouver des pépites dans le travail des
amateurs aussi
cette année on en a pas pour être tout à
fait honnête mais l'année dernière on en
avait un et on est oui plus sur une
photographie très pointue et
professionnelle mais c'est vraiment
parce qu'on a reçu des projets
principalement professionnels la
photographie c'est purement purement de
l'art un certain artistes vont préférer
le noir et blanc alors que d'autres vont
choisir le sépia ou les couleurs vives
bref la photographie offre un large
panel de choix artistiques vous êtes
vous-même photographe alors comment
est-ce que vous pourriez définir cet art
je pense que la photo
elle permet d'exprimer beaucoup de
choses et que c'est pour ça que les
photographes quand ils ont envie de se
confronter à cet appareil là pour
exprimer ces choses passent justement
par le noir et blanc parce que parfois
le noir et blanc ça va donner peut-être
un côté du sombre à ce qu'on a envie de
dire si c'est quelque chose dont on a
souffert par exemple mais parfois aussi
plus esthétique tout simplement le noir
et blanc c'est facile à aborder un peu
plus facile parfois que la couleur qui
ne bouscule à l'inverse si on a envie de
bousculer justement on peut aller vers
des couleurs assez vives je pense que la
direction
chromatique choisie dépend de ce qu'on a
envie de revendiquer
quelque chose ou un sujet en photo il y
a aussi la la couleur finalement la
retouche de la photo qui compte aussi
dans ce que l'artiste veut dire
primordial c'est à dire que il y a
qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de dire à
travers ce travail photographique et
comment est-ce que je vais faire en
sorte de de transmettre mon message quel
voilà quel média photographique je vais
utiliser pour pour le faire et c'est
vrai que les choix artistiques et
chroniques en font partie votre objectif
à travers les ménographies c'est
justement de redonner une nouvelle
visibilité à la photographie alors une
nouvelle sais pas mais en tout cas
vraiment de soutenir la visibilité de la
photographie je pense que c'est
important que que les photographes qui
ont justement des choses à dire dans le
monde
et la chance d'être montré pour pouvoir
le faire c'est un festival gratuit et
international il se passerait donc en
plein air est-ce qu'il y a un thème
spécifique autour de ce festival alors
on a on a trois thèmes cette année
on a un thème qui a été choisi par le
lycée Jean Monnet parce qu'on est on a
beaucoup travaillé l'année dernière avec
le lycée Jean Monnet autour de notre
thème sur le féminicide qui était notre
focus au féminin l'année dernière et du
coup par le biais des ateliers photos
que j'ai fait par la suite avec eux je
leur ai proposé de choisir l'appel à
candidature le thème de notre appel à
candidature et ils ont choisi le genre
donc on a un thème sur le genre on a six
photographes parmi la programmation qui
travaille sur le genre on a un
photographe thaïlandais on a un
photographe italien on a des phot
français c'est vraiment voilà les
projets qu'on a reçu un peu d'un peu
partout dans le monde sur ce thème
johnder le genre voilà on s'est rendu
compte que c'était une question qui qui
taraudait beaucoup les jeunes
aujourd'hui et du coup on s'est dit que
c'était bien d'en parler puisqu'il nous
l'ont demandé on leur a dit ok on se
lance on vous fait confiance et on part
sur ce thème donc il y a le thème du
genre pourquoi pourquoi justement je
rebondis sur sur le genre de poursuivre
sur les sur les autres thématiques
pourquoi vous tournez justement vers
vers les jeunes vers des des collégiens
oui c'est des collégiens lycéens vers
des lycéens justement pour pour avoir
une thématique pour monter une
thématique en fait je les ai trouvés
tellement
engagé dans dans leur discours quand on
discutait autour du thème du féminisme
donc l'année dernière je me suis rendu
compte qu'ils avaient malgré leur jeune
âge des choses à dire à exprimer et moi
je leur ai proposé qu'on réalise un
travail photographique ensemble ce
travail fait partie de la programmation
de du festival cette année donc il y
aura les photos des lycéens qui seront
exposés photos qu'ils ont fait même si
c'est qui dirigeait l'atelier et il
voulait travailler sur le genre pendant
leur atelier ça c'était vraiment un
choix affirmé concernant ce travail
qu'on allait faire ensemble donc je me
suis dit c'est pas un sujet moindre ils
ont vraiment envie d'en parler ils ont
vraiment des questionnements derrière
ils sont eux-mêmes en recherche de
compréhension par rapport à ce sujet qui
est présent dans cette génération qui
soit critique ou acceptée il y a un vrai
un vrai sujet donc je me suis dit
allons-y on lance appel à candidature et
on va voir est-ce qu'on reçoit j'étais
pas sûr est-ce qu'on reçoit des des
sujets photographiques autour de ce
thème évidemment on en a reçu et
finalement vous en avez reçu alors du
monde entier quels sont les deux autres
thématiques alors on a une thème un
thématique sur l'environnement on s'est
dit que étant donné qu'on était à la
campagne c'était bien de parler
d'environnement de temps qu'on est tous
assez
écologiste dans dans la bande je dis
dans la bande parce que c'est un
festival de bénévoles on est 34
bénévoles à monter le festival ensemble
et du coup voilà on a on a pareil quatre
de nos photographes qui sont vraiment
sur des thèmes autour de l'environnement
et de l'écologie c'était important pour
nous pareil toujours de la même façon
des photographes français mais aussi des
photographes étrangers dans ce dans
cette sélection donc ça c'est 4
photographes de la programmation et ça
on va le on va l'en créer un peu plus
sur l'année prochaine mais on y viendra
tout à l'heure je pense la dernière
thématique c'est la maternité
alors la maternité c'est toujours notre
focus notre idée du focus qu'on a dédié
aux femmes donc l'année dernière on
avait un sujet sur le féminicide un
sujet qui était fort cette année on est
sur un thème sur la maternité et on a
trois sujets sur la maternité pareil
encore une fois on a une photographe qui
viendrait public tchèque on a une
photographe qui vient de Taïwan et la
dernière photographe pardon sur la
maternité elle est suédoise il me semble
danoise elle est danoise pardon
alors les trois thèmes pour pour les
rassembler donc il y a la maternité de
l'écologie le genre finalement et on le
verra je pense à travers ce festival
est-ce qu'il y a plusieurs façons de
raconter justement la maternité
l'écologie et le genre alors tout
d'abord oui à ces trois thèmes mais si
vous venez au ménographies vous allez
aussi voir des travaux de photographe
qui sont pas sur ces thèmes là c'est un
peu ce qu'on appelle les coups de cœur
de la direction artistique c'est que il
y a aussi des sujets qu'on voit passer
qu'on a envie de présenter donc dans la
programmation il y a 21 photographes
donc le reste des photographes c'est sur
des sujets qui parlent de tout voilà
juste pour des sujets principaux mais
d'autres sujets on a parlé des
thématiques on va désormais parler
justement un petit peu des des
photographes vous nous avez dit 21-21
photographes internationaux comment
est-ce que vous les sélectionner comment
se fait l'appel à projet
à candidature
qui était cette année sur le thème du
genre donc là c'est 6 photographes et
après il y a une réflexion c'est une
vraie prospection donc moi je cherche
sur internet sur les réseaux sociaux
Consuelo qui fait la co-direction
artistique avec moi fait la même chose
et toutes les deux en fait on se
présente tout un panel de photographes
qu'on a trouvé chacune de notre côté
venant un peu du monde entier et on
choisit on met tout groupe et on choisit
ensemble et on dit voilà on a envie de
montrer ce sujet là parce qu'on trouve
ça beau on trouve ça important et voilà
donc c'est comme ça que se fait
l'édition et on fait notamment en
investit beaucoup nos bénévoles puisque
on fait une présélection disons de d'une
trentaine de
photographes et ensuite on présente les
30 travaux à nos bénévoles et on fait
une sorte de soirée commune de vote sur
laquelle les bénévoles vont choisir pour
les 20 20 21 projets qui seront exposés
à la fin c'est vraiment important que
tous ces bénévoles participent il y aura
également une partie hors les murs pour
pour ce festival je l'évoquais il y a
enfin on l'a évoqué ensemble il y a un
instant le festival est gratuit pourquoi
avoir voulu rendre cet événement
accessible à tous parce que je pense que
c'est important c'est important que la
culture puisse être accessible à tous
parce que quel que soit notre niveau
social on devrait avoir le droit de s'y
confronter d'avoir un avis et de s'y
intéresser et parfois le simple fait de
payer une entrée frêne cette possibilité
et du coup je trouvais ça vraiment hyper
important moi je travaille enfin je fais
du social depuis très longtemps j'ai
beaucoup travaillé avec des jeunes en
réinsertion à Aubervilliers par le biais
de la photo et je trouve ça important
que peu importe l'endroit d'où on vient
qu'on est accès aux choses comme tout le
monde voilà une quatrième édition je
suppose
on se donne du coup rendez-vous
probablement aussi l'année prochaine
merci beaucoup claire Pathé d'avoir été
avec nous sur sur sensation donc je
rappelle que vous êtes fondatrice et
directrice artistique des ménographies
la troisième édition des ménographies ça
se passe du 3 au 25 juin 2023 dans le
parc situé au Mesnil pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site ménographies.com ou sur Instagram
et Facebook @menographie au pluriel tout
simplement et pour voir ou réécouter
cette émission rendez-vous sur notre
site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]